well congressional Democrats are on a
collision course with the new acting
Attorney General Democrats who will
control the house in January bow to
protect special counsel robert muller
russia investigation from Matt Whittaker
Whittaker who was appointed by President
Trump last week has expressed skepticism
about the investigation Paula Reid is at
the White House with the latest Paula
good morning good morning any letter
that Justice Department staffers
Whitacre vow to run a department that is
fair and held to the highest ethical
standards
but his mercury relationship with the
White House and previous criticism of
the Russia investigation has some
Democrats worried that he will not be
fair and instead will be doing the
president's bidding the president wants
him to be the hatchet man to destroy the
Moller investigation Democrats including
likely House Judiciary Committee
Chairman Jerry Nadler are warning acting
Attorney General Matthew Whitaker not to
impede the Muller investigation we will
summon if necessary subpoena mr.
Whittaker Whittaker is a former US
Attorney and served as sessions chief of
staff for just over a year before he
joined the Justice Department Whittaker
called the Russia probe a political
fishing expedition he should never have
been appointed congresswoman Nancy
Pelosi who could reprise her role as
Speaker of the House laid out her
party's argument does violence to the
Constitution and the vision of her
founders to appoint such a person in
such a manner to be the chief legal
officer in our country Republicans say
the Russia investigation will continue
I'm confident
mr. Muller will be allowed to do this
job without interference the White House
has been trying to distance itself from
Whitaker who has visited Oval Office
several times in October the president
praised him I can tell you Matt Whitaker
is a great guy but on Friday I don't
know Matt Whitaker counselor Kellyanne
Conway tried to clarify this weekend the
president's point is it's not like he's
putting a friend in there who he's known
for his entire life
the president is deep in the process of
trying to select a permanent Attorney
General but some of the names that have
been floated including Rudy Giuliani and
Florida Attorney General Pam Bondi are
also Trump loyalists and Democrats will
likely try to argue that they too would
work to try to protect the president
from the Russian
Station John Paula thank you